later today the wife of the las vegas  man who worked as a translator for the  u.s military in afghanistan will arrive  on u.s soil and we can now share their  identities hekmat gauzy and laylee ghazi  were married last year she was awaiting  the proper documents to leave the  country but when the taliban took  control it was very dangerous and  difficult to leave last monday she was  able to get on a flight out of kabul to  kuwait she's scheduled to arrive at fort  lee on the east coast tonight  now it couldn't have happened without  ami that's allen medical international  which continues to coordinate relief  efforts for the afghan people it will  take several days for her to go through  the process before she arrives at nellis  and we of course will bring you that  reunion